unbelievable video shows the rescue of a
woman held captive discovered with a
collar around her neck chained to the
floor
officers found her on the second floor
of the home after discovering the entire
first floor had been barricaded
officers in Louisville Kentucky made the
terrifying discovery on August 16th on
the city's South side at about seven
o'clock that evening A call came in from
concerned neighbors reporting a woman
screaming body camera video shows
officers arrive on the scene
oh
[Applause]
early on officials realized the entire
first floor is barricaded off blocking
all doors and windows
yeah
but there is a a second floor window
open after the woman chained inside 37
year old Jonna Wilson kicked out a
window and began screaming
officers use a ladder found on the side
of the home to reach Wilson we see a
letter
at the top of the ladder officers find
Wilson crying with a chain collar and
padlock around her neck immediately they
ask about the suspect
oh
girl he did what
is he Hispanic the suspect was later
identified as 36 year old Moses May
Wilson's estranged boyfriend and father
to her child she later told police he
asked her to come over to clean the
house that's when he chained her up she
was there for about five hours before
being rescued
video shows officers follow the chain
from Wilson's neck to a bolt in the
floor officials use a hatchet to break
her free
but there's no one else in here right
now
once she's safely removed from the home
officials use hedge clippers to remove
the chain from Wilson's neck
authors
what kind of car does he drop May was
taken into custody two days later he now
faces multiple charges including
kidnapping wanton endangerment and
assault he's pleaded not guilty to all
charges and is due back in court on
Monday reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie